[Musica]
da sempre l'umanità si è mossa con
l'intenzione di superare i confini di
superare i propri limiti questo è il re
frenabile desiderio di andare oltre di
scoprire di sfidare di sfidarsi e già da
piccolo ci si sente un po esploratori
vogliosi di andare di scoprire e quando
hai tre anni riesce a superare di 30
metri gli occhi vigili di mamma di papà
ti sembra di aver fatto l'impresa
man mano poi con finiti dilatano la
voglia di andare oltre
aumenta in modo esponenziale
ebbene c'è nulla da fare la storia lo
insegna nel nostro dna ce lo dice siamo
fatti per andare alla scoperta
esplorare quando tutto accade non
sentivo in mad desiderio di superare i
miei limiti ma semplicemente avevo il
desiderio di sentirmi viva appagata
realizzata e così ho scoperto quanto
fosse bello assaporare i nuovi mondi
esplorare godere di nuove esperienze e
perché non farlo di corsa io sono
un'altra maratoneta ve l'hanno detto amo
correre e perché non portare con me
questa mia passione
in questa incantevole avventura
e così insieme alla mia amica corsa con
uno zainetto sulle spalle attraversato i
più grandi deserti del mondo
ho girato in lungo in largo continenti
spingendomi ogni volta sempre un po
oltre ma a volte senza nemmeno saperlo è
e ogni volta trovava una nuova
sensazione da assaporare
capi che andare oltre in fondo cavolo
era piacevole
ogni volta mi si apriva un mondo ricco
di emozioni
compresi che in sostanza i confini non
sono che i limiti prestabiliti e che non
sempre determinano una verità non sapere
qualcosa
è proprio uno di questi miei
sconfinamenti ho trovato la risposta a
questa mia ricerca un senso che ha dato
un nuovo valore e significato questo mio
percorso e che ora sono qua a
condividere con voi un pò di anni fa
trovai in mezzo i miei ricordi un
foglietto che ho disegnato a 14 anni
c'era una semplice d'una con un un
rametto mosso dal vento è sopra c'era
scritto vorrei sentire il rumore del
silenzio nel deserto
ricordo che mi era sempre piaciuta
l'idea di andare di poter andare in un
luogo isolato immenso dove ti senti
piccolo dove l'uomo non è protagonista
supremo e assaporarne questa immensità
il suo silenzio
in effetti non aveva tutti i torti
perché adesso che ho corso in tantissimi
deserti del mondo
devo dire che correre in un deserto è
una delle cose più belle della vita
prima di tutto è necessario una cosa
l'umiltà non si può pensare di andare lì
e di sfidarla perché se no te la fa
pagare non puoi pensare di di fregarlo e
tutte le persone che ho visto
personalmente che hanno avuto questo
approccio è l'hanno pagata cara con
colpi di calore colpi di sole io chiedo
sempre permesso di passare dentro di me
non lo dico nessuno come una preghiera
chiedo il permesso al deserto il
permesso di passare la vedo un po come
una forma di rispetto
e se lo tratti bene il deserto lo è e lo
ammiri aver lui ti regala delle
esperienze che arricchiranno per sempre
la tua vita mi è capitato di correre con
zebre antilopi in namibia
ho visto stellate meravigliosa ho
ascoltato il suono della sabbia
fischiettare sotto i miei piedi perché
in alcune condizioni metereologiche la
sabbia fischietta altro passaggio e poi
siamo al corso giù dalle dune si torna
essere bambini correndo giù dalle dune
ho avuto un sacco di pensieri un sacco
di miraggi poi e poi ho capito ho capito
una cosa ho capito quanto sia importante
la vita ho capito quanto a volte
pensiamo di necessitare di cose ma che
alla fine valgono zero quando si vive
una settimana in autosufficienza
portando tutto quello che serve sulle
proprie spalle si capisce davvero cosa
sia davvero importante e cosa no si
capisce quanto un cellulare sia utile ma
spesso inutile il cellulare non si porta
spesso ma sapete perché perché nel
deserto spesso non c'è campo non c'è
connessione e se anche se ne se ce n'è
io me ne frego lui se ne frega della
connessione perché non abbiamo bisogno
di facebook instagram internet non c'è
bisogno di nulla perché perché quando
sei lì hai voglia di essere lì e basta
lì è quel qui e ora
allora si scoprono quelle cose semplici
ma che avevamo dimenticato perché
inquinati dall'inutile la bellezza di
parlare con delle persone senza inserito
erroti da una suoneria la bellezza di
assaporare un brodino caldo poi magari
il freddo della notte del deserto oppure
semplicemente assaporare l'ultimo pezzo
di parmigiano reggiano che ti tiene vivi
nello zainetto condividerlo con un
coreano che in cambio il ritira gara
magari dei gamberetti secche gamberetti
secchi mangiati a colazione block ora
tutti prof comunque è qui in questa
situazione
in questi momenti qual è confine ma qui
esistono dei limiti dei blocchi non
accettare il mondo così com'è e
assaporare un momento e non dimenticarlo
più il tempo così rallenta
si riprende o meglio i propri spazi
propri preziosi secondi facendoci
rivivere tutti con estrema pienezza
ecco tutto ebbe inizio
in questa situazione e più precisamente
in africa è ancora più precisamente nel
mali lungo la falesia di bandiagara era
una gara che attraversava tutti i paesi
del dogma tribù meravigliosa che
racchiude una storia e delle usanze
misticismo incredibili per in mezzo alla
natura arida dove il silenzio aveva una
voce avvolgente quel torpore mattutino e
tiepido che solo l'africa ti sa donare
un africa di baobab parlanti dalla terra
dei tramonti rosso fuoco un'africa di
zone di sabbia polverosa dal caldo che
ti avvolge quell'africa delle migliaia
di stelle che ti fanno da coperta la
notte con quegli odori di specie ti
perdonano il naso e non li dimentichi
più
l'africa anche insomma divisi e sguardi
che ti guardano un po guardigli con
attenzione un po diffidenti è però poi
alla fine ti regalano sempre un sorriso
almeno un cenno di saluto in quel luogo
mistico trovato delle risposte che forse
cercavo anche da tempo
ecco ora immaginate una donna come me
alta anzi meglio una donna caucasica
alta un metro un aspirina e con delle
borracce addosso
e che corre in mezzo al nulla
in un deserto e io spesso veniva
scambiata per un uomo con queste calze
di compressione le donne potete
immaginare non usano correre non usano
correre e comunque usano vestire con
foulard colorati insomma una donna si
riconosce a distanza e io venivo
riconosciuta a pochi metri quando mi
vedevano in faccia ricordo in particolar
modo un mio ingresso in uno di questi
mille paesi attraversati
avevo alcuni tifosi che mi accoglievano
con applausi con applausi e poco più in
là vi di un bimbo avrà avuto due o tre
anni era completamente nudo
e al mio passaggio iniziò a piangere
scappare per i campi come se avesse
visto un mostro ero io ero io il mostro
infatti fece un sorriso accettando a
malincuore di essere l'orco cattivo
della sua giornata
abbassa lo sguardo e continua a correre
e poco più avanti vidi due donne le
sorpassa i e senti che una vicino
all'altra e zona madama zune abadan
usando il francese non la loro lingua
quasi come se volesse che io capisci
cosa stava dicendo allora mi fermai mi
girai le fece un sorriso felice e le
contrappo cambio con uno sguardo gli
occhi dolci lucidi profondi meravigliosi
ecco in quel momento
io senti una connessione con forte
legame con quella donna di cui non
sapevo assolutamente nulla non sapevo
che era sposata si era sposata non
sapevo l'età non sapevo proprio della
sua esistenza fino a 2 secondi prima
però in quel momento ricordo di aver
fatto un pensiero in merito questa
energia a questa empatia avvertita
eravamo entrambe donne uguali e
sicuramente anche se appartenenti a due
culture completamente diverse avevamo
qualcosa in comune
ecco io ebbi la sensazione che questo
nostro essere donne non aveva confini di
cultura religione era una comune
appartenenza un essere uguali
così mi resi conto che troppo spesso ci
poniamo dei limiti sia fisici che
mentali limitando territori persone
generi ea volte anche pensieri creando
quasi una gabbia intorno a noi dove
mente corpo rimangono confinati nidi e
opinioni culture e usanze a volte queste
sono meravigliose perché denotano
preziosa tradizione legami alla propria
terra coltura per altre volte sono
motivo di inutili lotte violenze e una
di queste forse la più barbare inutile e
la violenza sulla donna
e questo limite
questa cosa non ha ha sconfinato non è
rimasta viva
una donna su tre al mondo
secondo il ministero della salute è
stata violentata picchiata
costretta all'atto sessuale
oppure busato
almeno una volta nella sua vita
allora io dopo aver scoperto questo dato
tornei da questa questo viaggio
emessi e mi dissi ma chissà quante donne
ho incontrato io nella mia vita
su un autobus non bar al cinema
quante donne ha sfiorato senza sapere
che si portavano un mostro dentro dati
incredibili tristi e questo era in tutto
il mondo in tutto il mondo di nonna nei
paesi poco sviluppati lontano da noi era
in tutto il mondo capite ovunque allora
ho deciso di portare un messaggio
proprio in questo sconfinamenti
attraversando tutto il mondo dimostrando
che si si vuole è possibile superare
qualsiasi situazione ostile
qualsiasi ostacolo che la vita ci può
mettere davanti e spesso sono la mente
che crea dei limiti che ci convince che
non si può uscire da alcuni schemi
malati
ho deciso di dare vita un nuovo progetto
era il 2010 run for women dove per la
prima volta ho deciso di agire con un
fine permettetemi il gioco di parole con
un fine preciso mettere al servizio il
mio impegno la mia passione per qualcosa
di più grande
un messaggio universale che potesse
arrivare a tutti e dare un senso al mio
correre alla mia ricerca sperando
sperando così di migliorare la
situazione e superando qualsiasi confine
avrei attraversato in meno di un anno i
deserti di cinque continenti uno per
ogni lettera che componeva la parola
women e ogni volta che riusciva in
questo intento la lettera si sarebbe
illuminata
beh ovviamente non potevo pensare di
risolvere tutto il problema del mondo
però di farne luce si perché se qualcosa
non è visibile
noi non lo vediamo e se non lo vediamo
non possiamo interagirci
era necessario almeno provare ad
accendere i riflettori e dimostrare che
se si vuole tutto e possibile
e così corso questi mille chilometri in
cinque continenti usando le lettere
women
women2drive accendendo scusatemi il
mondo e cercando di svegliarlo da questo
coma di farlo reagire
a volte si pensa che alcune cose non
siano possibili e io intendevo
dimostrare che se io riuscivo a correre
per centinaia di chilometri a 40 gradi
sotto il sole anche tu donna violata
puoi uscire da questo maledetto tunnel
nero ma infatti il mio messaggio non era
dedicato agli uomini hanno fatte male
alle donne no era dedicato alle donne a
prendere in mano la propria vita a
magari chiede un aiuto a reagire
ecco il progetto fu apprezzato da molte
testate giornalistiche una in
particolare rava network alla testata di
settore
fedele una coppia di quella rivista fu
gettato persa non si sa da qualcuno
comunque cadde sul marciapiede milanese
cade a pancia in su e si aprì proprio
sul mio articolo è una donna stava
passando da rim era una giornata anzi un
periodo proprio triste per questa donna
le aveva addirittura pensato di farla
finita proprio quella mattina
il destino vuole che la donna è rivista
si incontrarono lo sguardo della donna
inizialmente arrabbiata perché qualcuno
aveva buttato giù per terra con la
rivista si posa su quell'articolo
eco run for women fece ritrovare un
pochino di autostima quella donna e fu
per lei un piccolo trampolino un piccolo
trampolino di inizio per riprendere in
mano la sua vita e capire che alla fine
era lei la protagonista della sua vita e
come tale poteva campione cambiarne il
copione ecco questa donna si chiama lina
mi contattò mi racconta questa storia è
tuttora ci sentiamo mi fa spesso gli
auguri di natale di compleanno mi
ricorda il dono che li ho fatto ora io
non so se ci sono altre donne me lo
auguro ma non lo so se ci sono altre
donne a cui ho cambiato la vita
però con certezza che una l'ho cambiata
e solo permesso n'è valsa la pena
la storia di lina e di tante altre mete
che ci si sono unite con me in questo
messaggio
in questa forza che ci unisce non solo
come donne ma come esseri umani
mi fa credere e sperare con forza che
uniti per uno stesso ideale sia
possibile superare alcuni confini e che
sia possibile lottare per quello in cui
si crede per il nostro bene per qualcosa
di giusto qualcosa che abbracci tutti
noi tutti noi insieme tutte e tutti noi
per questo corro per le donne per le
bambine che diventeranno donne per
quelle che non sono ancora nati ma che
nasceranno e saranno donne e continuerò
a farlo sempre col mio genero la mia
dignità la mia semplicità ma anche un po
di forza e lotterò per ogni cosa che
credo giusto e necessario questo mondo
ognuno di noi può fare la differenza
ognuno di noi può essere un esempio per
se stesso e gli altri
l'importante è agire anche la mossa dei
piccoli gesti perché un piccolo gesto se
x milioni di gesti diventa in ora
e tutto è possibile se si vuole farlo
a volte si mettono dei confini perché si
ha solo paura di guardare oltre
ma sappiate che senza la paura si corre
più leggeri
[Applauso]
[Musica]